all right we're just testing out these
lenovo laptops yeah they're the really
tough ones used by NASA in space
yeah we're told they're actually 64
thinkpads on the International Space
Station right now they used to use them
for their shuttle missions all right
so they've got a lot to live up to bats
around space and what ya do things
bounce in space yeah the other do yeah
well in that case we should use a
combination of our high-speed camera and
my next-door neighbor's trampoline to
simulate zero gravity with laptops it's
not all the real astronauts do yes yes
it's good so how is this anything by
being in space well if you're falling at
the same speed as the laptop and the
camera is panning at the same speed
following you down it'll give the
illusion of you floating in space with a
laptop what just jump up and down
yes
yeah I can see myself checking that
space emails on this yeah sww sww da
space wide web innit our space wide webs
yeah do you get YouTube in space you
must be able to I bet the astronauts
watch the slow mo guys in space all the
time what else they do there so
apparently these things are designed to
meet many military specifications for
toughness like serious vibration dust
thermal shock hot and cold temperatures
and that's before they be from outer
space as well I think we should get some
liquids involved they water-resistant
yes they are let's go
mark of war buddy always drowned
I like how desperately hard you're
trying to trick your space over there
you just like I'm really all need to sit
over about that everything through the
lap time for this right so hard to do
everything at once mm-hmm all right
let's see how the the laptop is fared
after being mug of watered
somewhat yeah our test is gonna be
playing this video yeah good what all
right I think we got to step it up to
the next level yeah I love doing that
walk bully right in the damn jugular
it's like a typical space situation
isn't it you like fend off the after the
killer space bullets
launched there so not only the laptop
survived that it saved you from getting
wet yeah so well bucket oh here comes
master Shi
oh that looks really like abstract
doesn't it yeah it's like I'm so I'm
freezing I still dripping how did you
get so wet from one bucket of water
that's how they're oh yeah yeah you see
ya wet on reform isolate my own still
managed to get wet yeah you just I saw
you just press control it say let's try
mug of water straight on the keyboard
all right let's do it over video test ah
still place like a dream it just had a
mud of water poured on it that's cool
that's pretty cool actually
each one that each key is a glove of
water yeah ah those are some exciting
tests Oh got a slight continuity error
in that the Sun is gone away and you're
completely dry I've drawn out a little
bit yeah a little bit where I can't do
much about the Sun but we can get you
good and wet again what's up well glad
the shots match now I'd probably check
my underwater emails of these so you
know you go meet up underwater web yeah
this with you well I'm amazed that these
laptops have actually survived every
test we've dropped them one far off the
trampoline and they've been soaked but
still work just great so really
impressive yeah brilliant press it we
can keep these laptops right yeah yeah
sweet
Wow